this is a production of Cornell
University
okay all right yeah so my thesis has
largely been developed into developing
computational searches characterized
plant specialized metabolism
um so if you're perhaps new to this
field one of the first things you might
be asking is why characterize plant
specialized metabolism and in answering
this question I'm also going to find
what I mean by a specialized vocabulary
so across all of the many thousands of
species of plants that exist today
um there is a wide variety of
morphological phrase that is actually
married by a very large diversity
neurofemical traits
many metabolites are produced across all
plants and even more across all
organisms yet within plant there are
many metabolites that are lineage
specific such as psychosin which is only
made in psychiatric equally we only
found in ginkgo biloba and Surround and
then boa are only found in certain
amount of dicot lineages and so when I
say specialized metabolite I mean a
metabolite that is either Limited in
what plants produce it or perhaps
Limited in what organs it is found in
or maybe under what environmental
conditions it's produced in
so as you can imagine across all of the
many thousands of species of plants
there's a very very large number or
estimated total number of plant
metabolites over a million
and many of these metabolites have been
studied and been found to have a useful
um
purposes for humankind such as
pyrethrins which are potent insecticides
and many specialized metabolites are
actually have
um those medicinal properties or potent
medicines such as taxon automotive and
they've been used in
medicinal
um for medicinal purposes uh sometimes
in since you know 18 times and we're
still used for my food today
um so the next question you might have
is well how are plants have a life study
so I'm going to go through a sort of
characteristic of people let's say you
take your favorite plant and you believe
it has antibiotic properties
so you take an extract of it back to
satellite and you determine through uh
antibiotic acids that this extract
actually does have the potential to feel
some important bacteria
and so what people do next is figure out
what specific metabolites are
responsible for this cancer that are
antibiotic properties
um and so they will use a variety of
analytical chemistry techniques to
determine the uh structure of these
particular metabolites
um and so one of the
machines analytical chemistry technique
that is very very widely used in
classified studies is mass spectrometry
and so this is a massive comment that's
shown here
um this instrument can detect hundreds
to thousands of metabolites in your
sample but it does not identify them
instead what it can give you for an
individual metabolite is the molecular
weight and this piece of information
here which is called a fragmentation
pattern interchangeably I'll call it a
Mass Spectrum
and what it is showing you is the masses
of substructors in your molecule and if
you know what particular molecule gave
rise to a particular fragmentation
pattern you can sort of piece together
what the substructors of this molecule
is
um but if you don't know what molecule
gave rise to it it can be very difficult
to determine the you know the compound
that is responsible for those
um so but you know let's say back to
this hypothetical example
let's say you have determined through
you know analytical chemistry techniques
the structure of your metabolites that
are responsible for the sciotic
properties
um and if you want to use this
metabolite in any sort of commercial or
clinical setting you'll have to figure
out how to simplify that and so one of
the first things people do is figure out
how the brain sympathizes and so this
involves figuring out what enzymes the
plant is using for synthesizing this
compound
um often people already know some of the
enzymes and still a useful extraction
and RNA heat techniques to figure out or
to predict the rest of the enzymes in
this pathway and then they validate the
enzyme's function so I can have doing in
visual reactions or perhaps potential
implants
um and additional essays they see the
expected uh come straight to the enzyme
and the cylinder they get the acceptance
and so through this process and pathway
and be elucidated
um and what I hope that you're
essentially coming away with here is
that these two that's going to
potentially be very time consuming so
um and so we're considering down to do
bottlenecks in the uh specialized
metabolism in my case this is largely
going to be involved with trying to lead
the ABC Wellness
um so I'm going to give a little bit
more background information on these
particular bottlenecks I'm going to
start with the bottleneck obstructive
information
uh there are software that exist to
take a fragmentation pattern and predict
what metabolizes what
unfortunately or
largely all of these
um they do not have they don't typically
have good performance from plants and
satellite because they are not well
trained to recognize like metabolite and
so they can produce many false positives
one method that is really easy and quick
and commonly used is called a database a
search for spectral matching and in this
process you are experimentally
generated math factor or fragmentation
patterns are compared to those in a
database and it's basically if enough
Peaks match or line up then you can
sort of you know saying well at least
this um molecule here that generated
this fragmentation pattern if it's a
good enough match you can say it is
exactly this molecule here that gave
this uh fabrication pattern or maybe
they're expected related
um however
this technique
also does not really have good
performance on plant metabolites mostly
because in public databases of
fragmentation patterns plant metabolites
are foreign
um and so the last bit of background I
want to talk about is on the pathway
limitation bottleneck and the main
corporate here is actually the
bottleneck is going to prediction
um so Within
plans at least
um Gene annotation across plant is
primarily based on what the uh annotated
function of the gene is in a rabbitopsis
which is this plant here
um the probably the best study plant on
Earth however this is a major problem
for specialized metabolism if these
genes are often personally evolving
culture example you might have one gene
doing a certain function of adopta and
because of frequency and duplication
events in the different lineages or any
different literation might be maybe a
presence and so it's difficult to
transfer the function
um to those themes if they're likely not
believe exact same thing
um furthermore within a rapidopsis only
about 30 of these are experimentally
annotated so the majority of these genes
that we're transferring function of
frosting cheese
um we're not sure what the function is
and an example of what this can lead to
um so there are uh software that
um or different algorithms that
on you know a global scale across all
plants
um predict which genes are acting as
which enzymes in specific Pathways
however they aren't for example for this
pathway there's 500 genes predicted to
catalyze this enzymatic step likely most
of these are incorrectly predicted
so the rest of my talk is going to
redevelop my thesis research which again
is
um trying to alleviate these different
bottlenecks the first one is the meaning
of the structure elucidation bottleneck
um the objective we've used machine
learning to provide metabolites with
structural annotations the goal of this
is to achieve Broad and quick
annotations of metabolomes with high
accuracy
um so I do want to give a little bit
more background to this before I go into
the results
um so I have mentioned that within
publicly available Mass Capital
databases there is a small fraction of
there's only a small fraction of
metabolize contained they're in relative
to the total number of plant metabolized
estimated internships across all planes
and so when people are performing uh
untargeted metabolic studies on plants
often what happens is the majority of
the metabolism detect so completely
unidentified
um so an algorithm that we devised to
provide an alternative method for
metabolite
um annotation is one that you know would
take a particular experience heavily and
instead of
providing the specific identification of
touching the metabolite it would instead
point out what chemistry are involved in
this metabolite so for example
um
okay this this particular metabolite
would have yeah
um so the use cases for such an
algorithm although it does not identify
from the satellite it can still be quite
useful for uncovering stuff also about
the metabolism
um and yeah for us when we started to
create such an algorithm or go over to
achieve better performance in
classification than identification
algorithms and also we particularly want
a good performance across diversity
um okay so now I'm going to go through
the training data sets and the methods
that we use to create this algorithm we
use two different data sets the first
one is focusing on the vision
this um repository that that we use has
over a hundred thousand total ribbons in
it importantly it these limits all have
their molecular formula
and it also has an in silicone I.E
computationally predicted fragmentation
pattern
um for each of the person within the
database and it contains for the
practice of lipids
um and so therefore we wanted our
algorithm to classify each of them into
its particular
um wow the second database that we had
is much more chemically diverse we took
about 30 000 total compounds a very
diverse so much reads from Tebby which
is the chemical entities of biological
interesting debate and there are many
classes within here it's a very diverse
um database but again what we wanted to
do with student algorithm and take a
metabolite and predict what's happening
so the first type of algorithm that we
bring to equify either lipids or diverse
uh chemicals was based just on
um molecular formulas these uh you know
every compound has an molecular formula
and which is a star contrast to the
relatively uh probably available
so in in making
um model or algorithms for classifying
based on molecular formulas we extracted
the numbers of common elements within
this formula and the ratios between them
and we also gave the model the
monolithic Island and this is the only
information that I've had for
classifying methods
um and again for this this first data
set since it has predicted effective
information for it we were able to take
these Spectra and then
um
feed that into the model in order to see
that this additional information
improves performance
so
um first I'm going to talk about the
results on the lipid data set when just
using molecular formulas to classify
lipids I'm sorry three metrics here of
the particular algorithm that we uh
frame
um increasingly
values that are closer to one indicate
increasingly Optimal Performance
and each dot is a particular with the
class so you can see that there are many
um actually
about half of the classes had really
high performance yeah unfortunately
there was another large portion of the
classes that had low performance and
these uh low performing classes
um always had either responsibility or
fought for economy had group and beings
are directly similar
um which meant that the molecular
formula for the purpose were either very
very similar or industry
um and so we thought that perhaps giving
instruction would increase performance
and although it didn't make you know
everything every class I buy it did
increase performance to all classes
um and then you know even when looking
at the um
model Solution that's just some of the
information uh we for a lot of lipids
we've had very high performance in
different careers uh to go ahead and see
what the performance was on the chemical
diverse data set
so first I'm going to show a breakdown
of the um different chemistry or
different classes that was having to say
with that and so many
um since classes
so we have some very large classes
celebrities aren't really structurally
they don't give you much information for
example hydrocarbon derivatives
is not very informative for biological
molecules they're most always
hydrocarbon derivatives
um but the ones that are more
informative such as lignin or alkaloids
aren't very well represented in this
database
um and so
what I'm showing now is the performance
of our model on these different classes
and again what we wanted to see was all
four of these metrics so offer these
color dots centered around one
uh we do see that for the large
um not very informative classes but for
the smaller classes unfortunately the
performance was not thank God and we can
sort of invest that many classes to not
be distinguished from each other basis
alone
um so we're next thinking well how to
proceed
um again given that for most metabolites
of most uh chemistry they're not very
well represented in public databases and
so fragmentation kind of information G
is not available for Real Estate
and so we also know that the formula
alone cannot really accurately take a
given compound and accurately tell you
know uh into and not accurately classify
it into the type of metabolism that is
involved in
so at this point we were
sort of wondering what to do next and
then another algorithm emerge to me for
the same questions uh it's called
cannabis it was developed by the docker
group in Germany
um and these are the this is the same
lab that developed Syria so this
um this algorithm was incorporated into
this sort of software suite
um and it answers you know it
is essentially more it has more
extensive applicability than our models
for the development of our model what is
likely required expensive extremists and
data collection to generate these
fragmentation patterns
this panel post is quick and easy and
free to use we decided to uh first test
its classification accuracy on a on
something house data that we had or you
know instead of looking at very diverse
metabolization just that well hit it
sorry
can I classify and otherwise we found
that it could I don't have the time to
go into that today
um but we have published this
information and if you can go find it on
my Google Scholar
um so in summary of objective one
um the models that we're trained in
molecular formulas achieve good
performance on a broad range of Select
satellite classes however for most
metabolite classes for performance with
a genuine
um the addition of spectral information
increases performance yet such data is
rising and available at the same
Candlelight
campus is an exciting alternative and it
presents wonderful opportunity for the
annotations of playing metabolism
so the next part of my talk is
um I mean essentially here now that we
have cancer how are we going to use it
um so the second part of my talk is
devoted to developing techniques to
characterizing and quantifying so I can
do to changes in the metabolism the goal
here is to understand how plants alter
their metabolism in response to stress
and uh we think that cannabis is really
going to help us do that
so
um in annotation yield uh Insight from
specialized in public that's what you
know I'm introducing here um so again
across all of the publicly available
sector databases is only about four
thousand for plants are presented and
this is much smaller than the estimated
total diversity of metabolites across
all plants
um so in order to address this to use
benefits for annotation
um we're using it to provide structural
information for a majority of the
metabolism particularly we want to
uncover stress the career metabolite
classes and assist and identification of
positive metabolism so I'll get to this
part in the third section of my talk
um okay how are we going to do this we
performed an integrated ormix experiment
from which transcripts and metabolites
were simultaneously gathered from Dr
Podium the staphyon in 17 different
tissue treatment conditions and again
we're doing this firstly to capture and
annotate as much of the parallel as
possible and later on I'll talk about
our second goal which was to alleviate
the pathway elusive Asian bottleneck
um so before we go into the open
Instagram in this experiment I want to
give some background into the equinox
and design again the goal here was to
induce as Many metabolic perturbations
if possible while studying economically
relevant conditions and I want to point
out firstly that this experiment was
generated
by a very large collaborative effort
between our lab in the veteraniac lab
and the Harrison lab and also the joint
Hume Institute
um so there's a lot of people to think
um so we chose to study gracophonium
this although it's not a crop it has
post-evolutionary evolutionary
relationship to the single Craftsman
energy graphics and it is much easier to
study than a lot of these species being
a model organism
and also our collaborators have worked
extensively with the species
um so the conditions that we chose to
study the first one was uh copper and
heat stress both of these conditions
negatively impact fertility across many
crops for this for these stretch we
collaborated with the battle Maniac lab
Experts of studying copper responses and
plants the second condition we chose to
study is a question like Horizon this is
not a compelling as well but for the
opposite reason as the copper or good
stuff
um this condition
um in in which the fungus provides
symbiosis sorry the fungal symbiosis
provides the same for minerals it has
been shown to increase trap yields for
different species and they can
contribute to sustainable soil
management and health and we are
collaborated with Harrison lab for this
they are definitely experts in studying
somebody else
so yeah so here's the experimental
design in all that story
um we have the symbiosis experiment here
in which we helped study of plants in
three different conditions of control
um low phosphate and the
um
sort of combined stress of uh symbiosis
in low phosphate however the spores when
um alleviating the symbiosis is
alleviating the low phosphate conditions
so this is fully symbiosis but for this
condition we do think of it as a little
phosphate stress
I'm sorry the second
um
conditions or sort of sub experiment we
devised is again looking at Copper and
heat stress so we have a little copper
finish I got a low copper straw so I
forgot a heat stress and one that a
plant that machine is combined uh copper
deprivation and heat stress we thought
that this uh this condition this
combined stuff would Alyssa the largest
changes in the Metallo compared to these
other two we weren't our hypothesis
wasn't totally not here which I'll go
into a bit later and then finally to
study different organs uh we sampled
leaves and colds and spikelets from
plants that went around and and scratch
unconditional
and again we're sampling both
metabolites and transcripts from The
Institute
and this study allows for extensive
metabolic preservations to be detected
and also cracking of conditioned
inducing fabulary classes
before I get to the Communist results I
want to talk about how the global
metabolones are impacted in these
different positions
um this goal here is to characterize and
will actually quantify uh conditioning
to change in the metabolism the metric
that I chose to do this with is the
relative difference practically index so
this measures the average change in
abundance of all metabolites in response
to each condition
um so what I'm showing you here is each
condition uh with the rdpi uh the green
class mirror for leaves and the brown
spots are for roots in the different
conditions uh one of the first takeaways
I want to point out is that Roots appear
more responsive than leaves that were if
you compare a root uh how much the root
metabolism is impacted in a particular
position do the leaf metabolism the root
is always higher
meiosis it does
this makes a lot of sense since the
condition is localized to the roots
um okay so now before we
um wanted to use panicist across the
whole diverse metabolism we plant
we wanted to ask how well okay Locus
performs on on diverse metabolized and
one of the first things I want to point
out when we use spectral matching to
identify the different metabolites that
we've detected in the stem only about
five percent of them were identified
however piano class annotates directly
81 percent of the metabolism so there's
a that's a big win right there I think
um so we use multiple methods for
recycling canopies performance and
process a broad array of different
chemistry
um the first one that we chose to look
at when comparing the predictions
between manifest and special matching so
for example if spectral matching takes
metabolite X instead of the final colon
those canopies take that same metabolite
and say take the rest of Apocalypse if
so then we're saying Panic if it's
correct and if not then
it's not worth it
um so for about 70
of the molecules that were identified
through spectral matching cannabis
um we've got about 70 of them Direct
and for an extra 10 percent it was close
it sort of got to the structural
neighborhood but
um didn't give us the exact correct
classification
um so the second method that we chose to
use to assess how well cannabis is
performing is to see if metabolites have
similar chemistry have similar
annotations
so what we used here is
um the first thing we did is we took the
fragmentation patterns the red different
metabolites and Quantified how similar
they work to each other and then map
them on to the network
um for example if if two nodes here each
node representing a particular
metabolite if they close together then
Etc are very similar and we can then say
well their structure is
most likely very similar as well
and so the colors of the different nodes
correspond to the fact the patient that
cannabis has given these different
metabolites
um so you know for example if you look
at this uh
sub Network here we have a lot of nodes
closely
um
very close together uh canopith is
um calling them all different these are
all fossil lipids here's another group
of
glycerolipids and then phospholipids
here another group of glycerolipids this
group up here contains many polypeptides
or
humoric acids this group is potentially
the most diverse
um but we still think there's similar
chemistries
um outlined in here Amino Rapids and
other
umoids perhaps small metabolites in here
um so on the whole I mean there's no
from this there's no definitive
quantifications to say how well symptoms
is doing but we on the whole speed the
similar chemistry is having similar in
the patients
and finally another method the third
method we used
um is comparing predictions between
Canada Fest and other lipidomic software
so
um there are other software that
um particularly just for lipids uh take
a particular and classify it uh into uh
in the class so what we did is we
compared well this software
call something that goes for cost a
little bit if so this payment is also
cause aggressive reposit within so we're
matching the annotations between these
two and again we find a metric that's
really close to 70 right
um so across all of these on the whole
we concluded that cancer shows the
performance one of this incorrects it is
indicating based on molecular
subtractions so for example if it could
potentially take a glycerol postulate
with insult it may be a fatty acel or
something like that so it's it's not
all together long
um so after that we did decide to use
the Cadillac parasite campus to
determine which metabolites are are most
impacted under different conditions so
we first used cannabis again for
metabolite annotations
and then we determine which metabolites
are up slashed down accumulated in these
conditions so either accumulated or
depleted
um and then we determine which classes
are on average most change in each
condition and a further sort of metric I
used was determining which classes are
enriched amongst the up or down of
cumulative metabolites this is sort of a
kinsu gold trim enrichment amongst your
let's say upregulated themes
um so I want to sort of walk you through
this figure before before I you know
I'll go over my concluders
um so for example if we take this
um the subgraph here uh this is the
um I'm showing the results here for the
roots under the proper deprivation and
each subgraph is showing a particular
condition all the roofs are on the
bottom all the leaves are in the top
each type of light class is shown here
represents a class that is highly
preserved under this on average highly
specifically this condition uh the ones
that are in purple are on average
strongly depleted the ones that are in
yellow are on average so they
accumulated and if a class has an
asterisk next to it
um it is English amongst the
strongly prepared metabolites in this
particular condition
so one of the first things that we saw
when looking across this whole figure is
that look at the peer globally stress
responses
um indeed if you look at the
um classes that are enriched in any
condition there's only two classes that
were ever enriched one was three
delivered and symbiosis fruit the other
was this were possible those that was
actually enriched across um
several different conditions and so
we're concluding from that but lipids
appear globally stuff just want to uh
perhaps because they're altering
um
before we you know different memory
Dynamics under these different
conditions
the other thing that we thought was a
little unexpected sort of interesting is
that whenever flavonoids are showing up
as a really perturbed back they were
different so here in uh proper Roots
heat roots
roots of the combined teeth proper stuff
also symbiosis there's flavonoids were
depleted in these different conditions
we're not we're not really sure what
this means but it was sort of you know
sort of antithetical to their role as an
antioxidant particularly under uh UV
stuff
um and so one other thing that I wanted
to do with campus is chart metabolite uh
coal accumulation pattern
um so I use clustering algorithms
combined with paint with this to uncover
groups of co-regulated metabolites and
then annotating metabolism
so this particular module here is I'm
sewing a screen interesting module for
me this one has metabolites that are in
above ground tissues and then are only
in Roots
um under somebody elsea and so we might
be metabolites that are traveling down
to the race to facilitate symbiosis
we're seeing potentially photosynthates
and Alpha fatty acles which are known to
be important in each facilitating
um this module here is showing
metabolites only found in symbiosis
Roots potentially you know
um they're either fungal derived or
potentially the plant is producing them
in this particular condition you see
fatal lipids which are important for
painting membrane Dynamics
um under this condition
uh in this module
um this is interesting because there's
metabolites down in the leaves and also
the swiper but not in the stem so I know
there's being produced independently or
independently in these different organs
or maybe there's transport that we just
didn't capture
um and this final
module here is showing the satellites
are either excluded from the uh
completely excluded from The Roots grown
hydroponically or only found in the
cytoplamically indicated at the might be
growth condition specific on the
satellites
um so one last thing that I want to talk
about in this section is a
interesting response to the combined
operating feature that we observed in
metabolism in the future though
so when I showed the rdpi or the
metabolone
um
what what we can see here I didn't talk
about this before but what we can see is
that the combined heat and copper stress
in The Roots is intermediate between the
copper alone in the alone this isn't
really the case in the league
um arguably it's at the same level as
alone and release but in The Roots it
appears intermediate
um I felt into this just a little bit
more looking at heat shock proteins and
food shock factors which are canonical
Regulators of the heat response and
plant
I started their expression in The Roots
under feet versus the routine of the
combined copper strap and although there
is no significant difference in
expression on the whole we did find that
for the majority of food such proteins
they are less expressed in this combined
stress than anything alone
um so we're not sure if this is a good
thing I mean it might be a good thing
um perhaps a less constructive
metabolism in transcription is
indicative of a less stress plant yet uh
perhaps critical recovery Pathways and
since we haven't
studied the recovery of these plants
after the stress we can't see which one
it is but it is definitely existing
phenomenon
okay so I'm going to wrap up section two
now
um with a summary of some of the key
findings so the rdpi calculation is a
promising way to assess a condition to
effect on the metabolism intensive
though
um canopy is definitely a useful tool
from the template education
Roots appear generally more responsive
than leaves and finally the heat of the
combined heat and heat stress and copper
deprivation elicited a loop from
metabolism
response in The Roots then the heat
stress alone
okay so this brings me to the third part
of my talk
um so previously I mentioned that we
wanted to use cannabis to alleviate the
pathway reservation bottleneck and I'm
going to talk about methods to do that
now particularly our efforts to use
integrative moments in Alpha and
facilitate metabolic path language
Edition uh the goal here is to quickly
associate pain in the themes of
metabolize in an untargeted approach so
um
okay assigning G two Pathways and aircon
um so I mentioned in the beginning how
traditionally pathway start with has
been targeted I.E people are looking for
enzymes that they believe to be for our
uh trying to determine if they're
involved in a given pathway that they
they've previously been studying they
probably know some of the enzymes
involved
but this targeted approach takes a lot
of effort beforehand to determine
um you know existing events in the
pathway uh existing metabolite
um and so
this uh Target approach can take a long
time to complete
however the eye target approach which
again we're looking at this pathway in
which uh genes were predicted to be
um uh are predicted to
perform enzymatic reactions in a
different pathway
um this this approach
um is likely yielding a lot of positive
predictions and incorrect predictions so
there's definitely room for other
approaches in this space
um and so our approach
um the goal here is to develop a
pipeline to assign fugitive metabolic
activity genes using cannabis indication
and correlation-based approaches
um and particularly we're using the uh
data that was generated that I've
described previously
um so I'm just going to jump right into
the pipeline that I developed for making
metabolic and the first step of it again
is to take the metabolites that we
detected in the experiment I described
and used cannabis to annotate them these
annotations
um given that they're not you know full
identification it can't pinpoint exactly
which pathway in the tablet life belongs
to uh if they were identification then
you would know what pathway or Pathways
that particular satellite is a part of
but cannabis annotations can give you
sort of a neighborhood of what router
metabolism a particular metabolite is
involved in
and then we also took the command strips
um that you know from dracopodium we
annotated them with any fugitive
function
um that we could
and then we used uh correlation
approaches to plaster them and in doing
so we are mapping internships onto the
uh sort of General routes of metabolism
that these metabolites are predicted to
be in
and so in doing this we annotated
12919 means in brachoponium to a general
lot of metabolism
um so this is on the one hand good
because we're you know annotating a
large proportion of the gene uh in
bracha Podium however this is far too
many to follow up on and so what we
wanted to do next was sort of prioritize
genes for further study and so we uh
decided to study genes that were
potentially important for symbiosa by
selecting transcripts with specific
upregulation in this condition and this
gave us 213 genes
um further we wanted to take one more
step we wanted to identify transcripts
who serve across teaching as these
um friendships then likely have a very
important function so we chose to use
orthofinder to identify transcripts and
gracophonium that had conserved genes to
sorghum and or medical and these
conserve these in a different species
ortholog and further we chose to look at
these two species because they have
experiments where people study symbiosis
in the roots and we can further then
select transcripts in Vaca Podium who's
orthodological differences breasts and
somebody else's in medical and orosodium
um and this podcast for 66 students to
choose from
um but in general you know you don't
have to apply this pipeline to somebody
else if you can apply it to any sort of
stress or condition you wish and it
yields broadly conserved means with
activity and stress response in
association with certain metabolic
classes
um so when we applied it to something
else it uncovered both known and novels
and biosis themes
um some of the a few of the known genes
that it identified as bracophonium from
T4 in phosphate transporter and ccu7 and
u27 which are enzymes involved in the uh
primary biocompensive pathway which are
important for facilitating
um symbiota
uh we also chose to study one novel Gene
this is the gdslip uh it had functional
conservation in symbiosis disorder uh
clustered metabolites with structural in
the patients high in specific expression
in sodium or sorry excuse me
uh importantly it had no convicted
parallels and these are genes within
brachopodium that could potentially be
doing uh having a redundant function so
since orthofinder predicted this Gene to
have no parallelog and so did for
further study
um I'm not going to go into like
everything that we did but I'll also
write it here
um we use the BPI transformation
facility to make Christopher cast and I
uh knockout mutations for this game
and then I uh screened and genotype the
progeny for selecting homozygous P1 line
um and then we grew mutants and wild
type plants under symbiota in order to
determine if there was any difference
between these between these two
phenotypes however I used uh
quantitative real-time rttpr to quantify
the expression of clinical morphogene
which directly uh correlates with how
much colonization is happening and it's
so no difference in colonization rates
within the wild type and so what we
think is the case is that there is
actually a functional hair log after I
got to this point we looked at all of
the ddsl glycosystems within graphic
Podium and started the expression and
the particular the initial lipase that
had the highest sequence similarity to
our game also has very similar
expression
um so I guess one thing come from this
is if you are using waterfinder to
annotate a large number of genes you
will want to do make jeans greens to
validate its predictions on a
case-system
um okay so in summary of objective three
with the addition of evolutionary
information our integrative homework
search flow was successfulizing
successful in identifying both known AMS
and novel genes however further work is
needed for validation of the important
importance of the target genes to
somebody else's and deterioration of
their specific metabolic activities
um so finally I want to go
just to really brief conclusion and
future perspectives on these two
different bottlenecks I'm just going to
talk about structuralism aging so we
showed that piano path had good
performance across chemically diverse
plant metabolites
um I think this could be an integer
um previously many studies when they're
looking at you know how different
um plants are changing their metabolism
in response to a certain condition these
Studies have focused on a small yet
identifiable portion of the catalog
potentially ignoring
other parts of the metabolism that might
be most affected by those conditions uh
hopefully canopress can change it
um and for pathway elucidation piano
presence is also helpful
um their annotations can narrow down
which Pathways metabolites they belong
to
um instead of having no item information
or what's in the template is and what uh
sort of metabolism or graphic metabolism
that's involved in now we can get sort
of general information about that and
then
um as we did studying public transitive
correlation considerably assign genes to
these Pathways an alternative approach
is to you know for example take some of
these enzymes that are predicted to be
involved in things in the pathway steps
of a particular pathway
and you can use poets professional
studies to predict which of these
enzymes are co-expressed and then
potentially likely to be involved in the
pathway potentially more likely than the
enzymes that don't show any predicted or
um expected extraction
okay
so with that
um
there's a lot of people that I have to
say
um I'm going to start with the people
here at Cornell who participlicated this
research
um first I'm going to highlight my
committee members especially Garo
um I can't even I don't have an estimate
for how much of your time you've spent
on just facilitating my growth as a
scientist and
um I
can't really thank you enough for that
thank you I'll try
um uh the rest of my committee members
Dr timato Brazil Frank's children and Dr
Rose
are uh you know also definitely
essential
um kept me from going down large and
expensive rabbit hole and also gave me
you know interesting ideas to think of
and explore during my FIFA I also have
to thank many many members of the movie
lab all of these people have helped me
not only with my research but you know
they took the time out of their day to
answer my questions
um and I had a lot of them so thanks to
all of you and also all of the
undergrads that either helped me with my
research or you know or I had the
pleasure of considering them
um it was really great to do that I'm
really glad I had that experience
um the experiment that we conducted was
in collaboration with the GGI and
particularly after doing Catherine Evie
Ben Bowen and christophnachio
um really just gave us so much
information
uh and also answer that question
um and then members of the better Maniac
lab and Harrison lab uh I would you know
go up to them again and ask them lots of
questions that they had the patients to
answer but also
um
help me with my research and which
everybody was just really nice to me and
made my time here so much better
um the Harrison lab you know same story
I must have asked
um Armando Bravo and Ian glancing so
many like maybe like 100 foxes recently
as a patient to you know guide me
through setting up a symbiosity never
done before
um I have to take my funding the USDA uh
NEPA Grant and also from the LCA on uh
growth chamber staff or wow fixing the
growth chamber whenever it had
unexpected problems administrative staff
or you know guiding me through any
website that I had come across
um and again just everybody here for
making my time just imaginably better
um I also have to thank the people that
helped me get here
um and also you know people at Cornell
that work directly uh responsible for
helping my research but again we're I
hope my growth as a scientist I had many
professions that I worked with my Iota
for them and learned how to be a better
teacher or took their courses and gained
a lot of Knowledge from that so thank
you to all of these people thank you to
my professions at Webster who not only
um made me aware that I was interested
in science but also were definitely loud
cheerleaders for me especially Mary free
um who just never gave up uh always
spent a lot of time a lot of her time
she you know pushed me in the right
direction
um I'm very grateful to her I'm also
very grateful to The Bachelor lab for
letting me into their lab as a complete
novice and just messed up everywhere I
had
just wonderfully patient members
especially Greg and Max I honestly don't
think I'm deep here without them
um and not only answering all my
questions but
going to need that a research
environment
it just could be really awesome
um also other members at the enforce
Center for doing the same thing being
wonderful role models and
um just allowing you to be there as you
know an underground
um
and finally
these are people that
just made my life so much better
um my friends and all of the Cornell uh
graduate students I don't have a lot of
pictures or often mention this but I
didn't put a smartphone until like May
so
um
I don't really get pictures of everybody
off of the website but
um y'all are here in my heart and you
know you're not in my talk
um my family I have to thank them we're
not the best decisions
for you know taking me outside of work
and having fun with me but also
um being forgiving when I didn't come
home for Thanksgiving
um and especially I have to thank my
fiance having shown here with a
dragonfly buddy
um for being one of the most supportive
people
um
that I have in my life and also
for just getting me through everything
in somewhere where you are
thank you so much
um and no I will take questions
lcms data for the um
having lcms data to having uh
so
um
in the part of the let me go back to
that slide what
we didn't actually do that for the data
that I presented here uh we had an
information already
so
um we already had for I mean you're
referring to the the liquid glass
database that we had where we took
information from lipids and classified
them into their respective classes
um the molecular formula and the
Federation time was already provided for
us we have done other experiments where
um we have taken
molecular formula and used other
prediction tools to predict the formula
sorry fermentation patterns and these
other thoughtworks
um
I can go into that I mean there's one
software that works very well that was
Emma Style
or sorry I'm a finder and then another
soccer
score
didn't work very well
um and we could you know quantify how
well the performance was because these
were standards
um so we knew working molecules
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu